en una nueva jornada de protestas contra
el joven el mois miles de ciudadanos
tomaron las calles de puerto príncipe
esta vez para rechazar la constante
violencia y los secuestros en el país
respondieron a una convocatoria del
personal sanitario tras el asesinato de
un médico y de una enfermera
esta es un movimiento del pueblo de
haití de todos los ciudadanos que
creemos que es imposible vivir en este
país no podemos vivir en esta situación
con barricadas ardiendo los
manifestantes pidieron el fin del
mandato de maurice a quien culpan de ser
incapaz de garantizar la seguridad de la
nación
haití ha visto recientemente constantes
secuestros principalmente de personas de
clase media a finales de febrero el
pediatra eres paddy fue asesinado al
resistirse a un intento de secuestro
pocos días después la enfermera del
inventor murió a manos de dos hombres
cuando salía de un banco cuando hay un
secuestro quiénes son las víctimas somos
nosotros los de la clase media los
médicos los abogados la policía
la agitación política se ha tornado
permanente en el país caribeño en medio
de una disputa entre la administración
de maurice y la oposición que asegura
que su mandato terminó el 7 de febrero
moix por su parte asegura que le queda
un año más en el cargo